hey Albert welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show clay dude how can I help
well is it okay if my wife's on the
other leg sure okay and um this is what
the way the situation is I have our
40,000 in the in the bank and I'm not
sure what to do with it
whether to put it into the house or some
kind of IRA okay well what we teach
folks to do is to take every dollar that
they take captive of and work a detailed
thorough financial planning process
called the baby steps baby steps from
baby step one save a thousand dollars to
is to be you've done that to is to be
debt-free everything but your home I do
you have any debts other than your home
no okay you've done that one then baby
step three is to have a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses a rainy day fund so when it
rains you've got some money does that
make sense that you have money other
than this forty thousand eighteen
thousand stables and that's your
emergency fund okay not to be you not to
be used to buy a car or a couch or a
trip that's only for emergencies
okay cool do you have anything that you
have anything that isn't that you're
needing to purchase an upgrade in a car
or is there anything like that that's on
the horizon that you need to take care
of what do you say ma'am hey everybody
we're 70 years old we don't have a
retirement fund so what should we do
with this money
put it in our house yeah I understand I
heard the question I'm working I'm
walking up the baby steps and so you've
got your emergency fund in place and
you're 70 years old how much do you have
in retirement savings just thirteen
thousand okay we suggest putting fifteen
some of your income away for retirement
savings how much do you owe on your home
140,000 okay what is your income your
household income 2800 that Social
Security and I have a part-time job okay
and you can live on that well it's gonna
be tight but yes okay well you're gonna
have to I guess it's only one of you
guys right right okay so cuz if you
invest this money or if you put it in
the house and either way is it there to
live and live on it's going to be
working on one of those two things and
really either one of them is a good
answer I think your nest egg is
devastatingly small and so I'm gonna put
the money into retirement okay your
entire your entire nest egg is currently
$13,000 that understand that yes and
where did the forty thousand come from I
I got injured at work and uh it's they
settled with a certain amount of money
yeah okay
so yeah that needs to be invested for
your nest egg so that now you've got a
fifty three thousand dollar nest egg and
we'll let that grow and you know in
about six or seven years if it's
invested in good mutual funds on average
it will double and so you'd have about a
hundred thousand in there and that
starts to be a little bit more
comfortable meanwhile you're beginning
to tick away at the house and try to get
it paid down and paid off because I'm
you know our goal is twofold here we
need to paid off house and a good-sized
mystic and so I don't know which of
those you're gonna reach first or are
you going to reach them simultaneously
but that's they're both good goals and
they're both really the only goals you
two should be working on right now if
you need some help investing and you're
not used to doing that all the time and
it sounds like you're not click smart
Wester at Dave Ramsey comm and when you
fill in your information it'll drop down
a list of people in your area called
smart investor pros that we endorse I am
NOT in the investing business but these
are guys and gals that are have the
heart of a teacher and do stuff the way
you hear me talk about it here on the
air and you will
stand what you're doing when you're
working with one of them
and if you don't understand it don't do
it because when you put money and stuff
you don't understand it keeps you
freaked out and you can't sleep at night
and you should be freaked out and can't
sleep at night if you don't understand
it because you're probably gonna lose it
so always understand what you're
investing in and their job is not to
pick an investment for you their job is
to teach you and then put some
investments in front of you that you
pick and they'll show you how to do that
that's a big deal right there and that's
a new experience for you guys in but do
it anyway go learn something new it's a
good thing